this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we are here with the
godfather of minimalism all star of
minimalism
oh my god i was just thinking about when
when i first saw you i'm like
man leo we started like
10 years ago and you were one of the
first people that we had lunch with and
kind of talked about what we were doing
and uh yeah in san francisco at uh
samovar
that's right yeah we have some of our
tea right now yeah yeah
shout out to sam levar uh jesse over
there he was in our documentary that you
were also in
as well jesse's one of my best friends
he's he's yeah he's the best i i really
really enjoy him i really enjoy you i'm
grateful you're here i am
astonished that we have never had leo on
the planet no
i know he finally said yes to us i know
i think i've just been scared to have
him on because
he's going to outshine us that's true
those are the best guests
when the guests can carry it for us that
makes it so much easier so it's going to
actually go now
minimalism he's gonna like
uh get rid of sean and jordan along the
way but so
so um i gotta say this leo and
and you're okay with taking compliments
here but you're
you're literally the coolest person i
know
that's speaking more to the quality of
people you know
sure i'll take it i agree with that it's
like it's hard to be around leo and not
be
relaxed yes yeah yeah so a great
compliment yeah
leo let's start by we were first
introduced to you so i was first
introduced to minimalism
11 years ago okay colin wright someone
had
retweeted a video of his uh my good
friend colin now but
at the time i had no idea who he was and
i saw this guy who owned
52 items and it was kind of admirable
but i'm like i don't want to do this i
have a house and i have a couch and i
have a
coffee table and all these things can't
fit into an overhead bin on an airplane
but all of colin's things they just fit
in his
little bag and he traveled the world and
that was cool
but i didn't want to mimic that
lifestyle but
from colin i i saw these different
people
who lived more normal lives like joshua
becker courtney carver but he also
introduced me to your work
and then i see this guy he's a
minimalist
and probably the most minimalist of
these people i'm looking at but he has
six kids right he even decluttered the
condom
threw him away
you're just said in that lineup this
whole time yeah um
yeah so i tried to declutter them but my
wife wasn't having it
we actually got rid of a couple of them
out of our house now oh yeah
we're slowly that that's a that's the
last thing that we
are doing it takes time to let go yeah
talk about taking time yeah
yeah well do you want me to speak to to
being a minimalist with six kids
yeah i'd love to at least touch on that
so i mean first of all
our kids we had them before we decided
to become a
minimalist so we were maximalist at the
time right we were deeply in debt
we um we just had a kind of crazy like
cluttered lifestyle and
that was a different kind of lifetime
and we started changing
and so that we we run up against like we
have a big family
right like how do you downsize and
simplify with a big family
and i actually found that first of all
it was like a challenge like okay how do
you
it's like this mental puzzle right how
do you simplify with that many people in
your house
and then i saw it as like oh this is
opportunity right so how do we look at
this as something
that we can really like dive into
together and so with six kids it was an
opportunity to teach them about some of
the things that i was exploring and to
explore
together as a family so we could you
know kind of like connect
on that level um so i really started to
enjoy that
i mean it didn't have to be about like
having you know just three things or
anything like that yeah but it was more
like
what was important to us as a family to
end to each of us and how do we work
with
having different preferences which as
you can imagine well i know you
you have a wife and kit so that that
like
um becomes a negotiation or like a way
of like
relating to each other um we can't just
like take someone else's stuff and throw
it out
give it to goodwill or anything like
that you have to kind of have a
conversation sorry kids dad's a
minimalist
yeah so yeah it actually became
really rich ground for us to explore
together yeah it's awesome
i find that the the communication is
obviously key
but it did start with you you you um i
think
20 2009 to or 2007 maybe is when
zinhabits.net starts
2007. yeah that's right wow
um and and so people can obviously go
and find
over a decade of archives there and
i was exposed to your work there because
i think it kind of started as this
productivity and habits
website where you were writing about
your own journey trying to make some
changes in your life can you talk about
some of those initial changes
early in 2007 that yeah you started
writing about
yeah actually january 2007 was already
more than a year
into my journey of changing my life so
it really started i believe november 18
2005. when i um i was in a
we're living in guam we had five kids
and one on the way so she was about to
give birth
in a few months and i was a smoker
i was much heavier than i am now i was
sedentary i was a procrastinator
i was deeply in debt and i could list
like a whole bunch of other things that
i was really unhappy with
and the worst thing was i felt like
stuck like i couldn't change anything
and i just couldn't figure this out and
i knew there's some there was a way to
do it
so like i decided i'm just gonna do one
of the many things i was trying to
change all at once
i'm just going to pick one and it turned
out to be smoking and my quit date i
i set it like two weeks in advance was
november 18.
did you smoke like three packs of
cigarettes leading up to that day we got
to
everything that i had um but it was like
the the reason for that was i had been
just quitting like okay i'm gonna quit
today like as if it was no big deal
and then it would be like you know like
almost like i'm gonna i'm gonna take out
the trash today you know so
so instead i was like i'm going to make
this a big deal something that i'm
really committed to
and build my way up to that so all the
way up to that i actually started to
figure out what the different triggers
were
that caused me to smoke and feeling the
urges and looking at
like what was rewarding about it why did
i need it and so i started to
really look at that and then i actually
quit on that date and i actually made it
stick this time and i had failed seven
times before that
so yeah that was the start of the
journey i i started running
i couldn't run for 10 minutes by
december 2006 right before i started
zen habits i ran my first marathon wow
so yeah
it was i changed my whole my diet
became a vegetarian now i'm a vegan
i started simplifying my life we started
decluttering we started getting
rid of debt and on our way to like
paying all that off
um waking earlier you know writing
when i hadn't been writing for years so
all
everything changed and so zen habits was
not the start of it
it was like a celebration of that and i
actually when my first post was like
2006 was an awesome year and i share
like all the things i've been doing
and then this is what i want 2007 to be
and so it was like
uh committing to continual change and
reporting on that and then learning from
people
who i was connecting with through the
blog man this just reminded me like how
inspiring it was because that's where i
was at man i mean
massive amounts of debt uh way worse
habits than smoking i wish smoking was
the only bad habit i had picked up
but um yeah it's truly inspiring man
like just to see you be able to pull out
of that i mean it's certainly what
inspired me to
to to change definitely man yeah really
appreciate it and
and there were people who were inspiring
me to change too i i was reading blogs
and
and authors and reading about these
kinds of journeys as well and so i knew
the power of that and i knew like i had
to do that in return just to kind of
give back because
the next leo who was stuck in his life
was going to be out there and maybe it
was ryan
amen yeah well it's funny because people
ask me like you know
who who do you look up to for
inspiration and i bring you up a lot
because it truly was like the precipice
of
uh or the impetus the whatever the
beginning of my journey
um so who were the people you looked up
to back then yeah i had
well um do you guys know jd roth yeah
yeah
get rich slowly with his blog yeah so it
was it was about getting out of debt but
really doing it in a very
like not trying to like get rich quickly
kind of idea
so i i really appreciated his humility
and um just really this kind of like
common sense but like
do things one step at a time change your
habits and
um so that was an inspiration there were
others as well
i can't remember now there were there
were definitely lots of fitness
inspirations that i was looking at um i
remember like oprah ran her first
marathon
at the time and i was like man if oprah
can do it i can do it right
i love it yeah i mean not that there's
anything wrong with her doing it she was
that was definitely an inspiration but
it was like man like
she can do it and she was really
struggling with a lot of stuff
and so like i'm struggling like why not
right
um and so there were there were a number
of inspirations like that for simplicity
i didn't think of it as minimalism at
the time because that term wasn't really
a thing
sure um but for simplifying your life
there was this author from the 90s named
uh
elaine st james you guys know who she is
yeah so she had these little books and
it was like 100 ways to simplify your
life and so i'd read through those and i
was like oh man that's amazing
yeah so and then of course like going
back to like
um thoreau and like walden that kind of
like living the really simple life and
then like um
you know uh taoism and things like that
were also inspirations in zen
sure obviously was a big one for me
right right yeah we're going to touch on
all of that in fact
i also want to talk about i want to get
into the granular details of
the journey and also moving around
you've moved a lot you went from guam to
san francisco to
davis to back to guam to san diego to la
and there's probably other places that i
missed in between
and i want to talk about all of that
we'll probably get to that on the
maximal i also want to talk about
how you move with eight people in your
family or more we can also talk about
the more part
um and but we are a
audience driven show so i figured maybe
we could help some folks like you've
helped us
so maybe we could help some folks uh
with their questions here i would love
that
we'll start with giselle in new york
city i was wondering if you guys have
any advice for a 21 year old who's been
minimizing for a year now
i reached a point where i'm content
because everything i owner presents
really does bring me joy
um we live in a tiny new york apartment
since i was born
and beginning the journey i realized how
much stuff has accumulated since my
boring day
and i mean even before that there's
quite a number of family in the
apartment and i was hoping on some
advice that would help me introduce
minimalism to the rest of my family
so leo we have a 21 year old here i
think you are a father of
oh well you've been a father of several
21 year olds at this point right
now okay wow wow man it's incredible
it's hard for a guy who's 35 to have 21
years yeah right
i started very
so so um gisele is
struggling but also asking the right
questions it feels like
sure she's also wanting to inspire the
people around her it seems like she has
changed her mindset changed her habits
but now she's asking like how do i
continue to do that because i have too
much
stuff still or the house in general is
too much stuff
but also the people around me um i see
they're struggling as well how do i help
inspire them
yeah there's definitely a lot to dive
into there i think the first thing is
just celebrate how much she has been
doing a whole year is worth of
simplifying is like
incredible and we can always look at
like how much is left is like ah there's
still
so much more but like a year of doing
that
is really something to celebrate and
really to see what she's learned from
that
what she's able to let go of and what
really worked and then to start to apply
that
going forward that's always worked for
me is like okay what worked with
quitting smoking that i can now apply to
running
right and so i just keep applying those
lessons over and over and maybe what
didn't work as well so you don't carry
that forward yeah
yeah and then like the next one is um
looking at what you're kind of stuck
with because there's you know
i heard her say like everything i have
gives me joy right
which i'm like that's amazing like why
do you want to get rid of it then right
there must be a reason
um and but i'm also hearing is like it's
it's too much it's really kind of
overwhelming me is probably where she's
coming from
and so it can't actually all be giving
you joy and
like you know being too much for you and
overwhelming you so
yeah um i think there's probably an
opportunity to find the things that give
you the most joy
and really to say like if i had a life
that only had this stuff
like okay i'd have to let go of some
things that do give me joy
but this is actually would give me more
joy to have more space in my life for
these things
and it's not just about things but those
would be kind of like an example of
something to look at
um and so then why what if
she was going to do that and say okay
these things would um
making space for these things would give
me even more joy and letting go of these
things
would give me that space what's what's
stopping her from getting rid of those
things
is what i would look at yeah and there's
usually some kind of like emotional
attachment
and i actually find that harder to work
with but actually
much more rewarding if you can like
learn to work with the emotional
attachments of like
ah this is my grandmother's thing or you
know something like that
um or like i'm gonna read this stack of
books that go to the ceiling right
uh like of course you are yeah you
haven't yet but um
i mean that's that's the story i tell
myself is like i'm definitely gonna get
to all these books and i haven't read a
book in the last six months
um so so i would just look at the
attachments that she's having and those
are really rewarding things um and then
the other thing i
you know i'm sure you guys could give
some amazing answers to these too i'd
love to hear your perspectives but
um around other people something that
i've really found is
it's really hard when you think like i
can just go in there and change their
lives because you can see
all of the all the answers you have like
you have the way to fix them
right um and that of course you guys
know this never works
right like everyone's gonna be like stop
trying to get rid of my stuff and like
try stop trying to tell me what to do
and stop judging me for having too much
stuff
and then like we just stopped talking to
each other because we haven't
we're like oh this is like too
frustrating um
and so i i learned the hard way of
trying that many many times that that
doesn't work
yeah and so for me what always works is
first of all
inspiring which you guys spoke to
earlier if you can show your journey and
talk about
you know how that's really benefiting
your life and how much you're loving it
it really kind of opens the door for
people to be like huh maybe i should try
that and if you can do it in a
non-judgmental way where they're not
like
trying to defend themselves you know
what i mean like ah like she's
she's trying to show me how her life is
better than mine
and how i should be doing this too is
really kind of like the subtext
of whatever she's sharing on instagram
right like i think definitely share on
instagram but
see if you can do it in a way that is
not judging others but really just
celebrating
uh what you're really loving about this
and even in a vulnerable way like oh
this is so hard to get rid of this um
and
like sharing that this is not just all
like
amazing stuff but actually you know it's
it's a struggle but a really rich one
if it was i think that's a problem we
often confuse simplicity with easy and
also
the the joy part you were talking about
if you're overwhelmed with joy it's
probably not joy it's a static pleasure
like
like you're getting some sort of in
momentary
yeah all these things bring me pleasure
that doesn't mean they all bring you
joy and i think we need to be able to
distinguish that because
yes any of your things has the ability
to potentially
give you pleasure that's not a good
enough reason to hold on to it because
if it's getting in the way it's actually
doing the opposite of bringing you joy
sure you know uh if josh would have came
to me and said
hey ryan you need to be a minimalist you
need to get rid of your
new cars you need to sell your condo and
you need to simplify i probably would
have
said exactly what what you were talking
about when you tried to force minimalism
on others are like why are you
i would be like why are you telling me
this why are you judging me why are you
at gunpoint right
you don't have the guts to pull that
trigger i would actually like to see
that movie
become a minimalist now joshua fields
milburn is the minimizer
oh man i makes me think of the new
yorker cartoon where did you see this
where the uh
the dude was like tied to the chair and
like all these robbers were like
carrying out the very last thing and
one of the robbers looks over and he's
like this is your chance to restart your
life don't screw it up
[Laughter]
there's a silver lining in all of this
and i totally agree with what you're
saying about the attachment
and and i think that is the key here and
then also not being judgmental ryan and
i will often we often say this phrase
you can't change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
meaning you can't you you can't force
someone to change you can demonstrate
what changes you've made and they may or
may not be applicable to them
it's okay to be surrounded by people who
have different preferences different
hobbies different beliefs
in fact that makes life really rich i
think the key is like ryan and i are
radically different
different politically different
religiously like uh spiritually we're
different we have different
personalities you should see all the
crystals josh has
[Music]
it's crystal meth
that's where you get all that energy so
hyped up right now um
these are not real teeth uh so
but we have similar values and so the
thing i'm gonna tell giselle here is
uh what's nice about having different
people in your life it brings passion
and excitement and
joy to your life to have different
people but they you probably want
similar values values are the
destination
the beliefs are the sort of different
paths you take to get there so leo and i
might have the same values we might take
different paths to get there
sure and and think about that when
you're thinking about the people around
you
respect appreciate don't just tolerate
but appreciate
the beliefs that they have that might be
different from yours
and then appreciate that you have
similar values to them and if you don't
have similar values to them well then
that's a different conversation
i would encourage you actually to check
out we have a values worksheet on our
website
the minimalists.com v you can download
it for free
and uh there's an essay there where we
sort of walk you through
the four different types of values and
giselle i think what that'll help you
identify is what your values are
and that will help you figure out
whether or not those values align with
the people
around you let's walk to another
question here with krista
from wisconsin i'm a minimalist already
and
i've already removed most of the excess
stuff from my life
i also have ocd though and i'm at a
point where rather than living better
with less
i'm living to minimalize
that is i feel driven to get rid of
everything
with ocd i am driven to take things to
extremes so my to-do list
as it currently stands will not be
complete until
essentially i'm living out of a backpack
but this is not logically possible for
me i've got a husband
and daughter and a wonderful little 800
square foot house
but i now have this never ending task to
get rid of more things
i mean we can do cartwheels in my living
room and half of my kitchen cabinets
are already empty and i am receiving
professional treatment for my disorder
do you have any suggestions or thoughts
on
how to know when to stop getting rid of
things
so leo i have ocd like legitimately um
yeah yeah and um it's it sounds actually
rather similar
to krista's ocd not in the sense that
because i i know i know some people have
ocd where they have to touch a door
handle three times before they can open
it thankfully i'm not burned by that but
i do count a lot of things like i know
there are 44 steps between
uh on in the parking garage from where
my car is to the
yeah and so like i i don't do that
intentionally but then by the end of it
i'm like oh what
that was 44. um and uh
it i will tell you this it it is maybe a
slight struggle but it's not an extreme
burden on my life
in fact in many ways it makes life
better uh in some ways
um but what dude your house is beautiful
thank you because of the ocd nature
i go to his house and i'm like now this
is what a minimalist house should look
like
like it's everything's nice and crisp
and clean but for me to do that
it would be so much work but for you
it's like it's excessive for you it's
not excessive for me exactly
now leo the thing that the phrase that
stood out to me with krista's question
here
she talked about she wasn't minimalizing
to live a better life she
felt like she was living to minimize
let's talk about that man actually i'd
love to hear your perspective
uh because it's something that i think
you would uh really relate well to
um but i i can relate to it
uh to to you know within my experience
is um
yeah sometimes the so it's actually
great to examine our reasons i love that
she's doing that
um and so like yeah am i doing this to
like
share something on you know social media
so that i can like look
like a minimalist and like really
glamorous or something like that
and so just looking at that and that's
not to make that wrong or like
something's wrong with you for wanting
to
look good to others right like we all do
yeah so it's not about
like making ourselves wrong but just
really looking at like where is this
coming from this need to minimalize so
for me
often it's like i i can't deal with
overwhelm
and so that's that's really hard for me
and so simplifying really allowed me to
have the breathing space but
it also allowed me to not have to face
overwhelm and to
work with that so now i'm i'm kind of
shifting into that like okay
i got rid of everything and got some
space but
actually i would like to be powerful for
me not to have to run from
overwhelm um and then can i ask you
about that because
yeah to my record my recollection you
are
a pretty extreme minimalist on uh even
though
maybe not everyone in your family is and
chris is in a similar situation here
she's like
hey i could live out of a backpack but
the rest of my family couldn't and
my response to that is well it actually
sounds a lot like leo i think he could
live out of a backpack
actually probably he could live out of a
fanny pack
and i remember i remember reading some
stuff
early on where you were like washing
your clothes in
the sink as as a sort of a mindfulness
exercise
right and and uh there are different
things you've done where you sort of
temporarily deprive yourself
not for the sake of deprivation but to
see
what is truly valuable right and and
living more intentionally through
through that space
yeah so for me it's always just like
experiments in life you know like
learning
a learning process so if i if i'm trying
to like live this way i'm like oh what
would it be like to like
have to wash my clothes or to you know
wear you know go barefoot for a while
and so like i did those things
yeah and it's not because i think that's
the only way or that like this is going
to make my life so much better but it's
just like
you know what what's getting in the way
of that maybe there's something there to
look at
so i'm always kind of examining that and
like i said the overwhelm was one of
them we're like
why am i running away from overwhelm is
there something there
um and so yeah it's for me it's always
just like
about examining that and by the way i
know you've kind of made some references
to like
how how little i have it's not like that
anymore
these days i'm not like i'm not a i'm
not a hoarder
um but it's it's not quite to the
extremes that i
i went to like maybe a decade ago it's
the same for me but it's also different
because when i
first embraced minimalism you know my
mom died my marriage ended in the same
month and i'm
i'm i'm was living a different life from
what i am now i
i didn't have a wife or a kid and and so
as your life changes the things that are
appropriate for your life changes
right and so it sounds to me like a
decade ago what was appropriate is
different from what's
maybe appropriate now yeah so like we
we moved to davis and uh from san
francisco
and everyone there rides bikes and we
didn't have any bikes and so we got
bikes and some things to fix the bikes
yeah so like now we have like a garage
that had like a you know bunch of bikes
in it yeah
and so like i i have no regrets about
that i actually think it's amazing yeah
of course um but it's definitely
not it does it's not gonna look
minimalist you know you have a bunch of
helmets and you have a bunch of other
things
yeah um and that's just one example i
got into trail running and i was
training for an ultra marathon so i got
a bunch of trail
running stuff probably way less than
most trail runners do
but still it was like it added to my
life and then i got into like
ultra light backpacking where i would go
out for
um you know a couple days just with a
very light backpack and
almost no nothing in it right and um
there's a bunch of macadamia nuts quinoa
exactly
exactly as little as possible i'm like
oh what would it be like to go out into
wilderness which i was kind of afraid of
like when i go out into wilderness my
first instinct is to like have a bunch
of stuff to protect me right
so that i i don't die right right that's
a very real concern but it's like oh
can i find a way to address all of those
fears
um you know in other ways without stuff
and so
it was it was another experiment but
what it meant was i was
on amazon buying stuff and i'm like am i
really minimalist now i'm like
who cares like i really want to like you
know go into this area and explore it so
i didn't want to hold myself back just
because of some
ideal that i had but also knowing you
yeah i would just say there's a couple
really good lessons here for crystal one
is
is that you know minimalism isn't this
destination it's a tool that we use to
really figure out
how we can be ourselves and that's
really like what i just heard you say is
you found out over the years how to
really be yourself how to be the most
genuine version of yourself
and that's really what i would recommend
uh christy to do here is not
get to this mindset of oh if i just get
to the backpack yeah then i'm gonna be
happy because
i would posit that if i snapped my
fingers and made it so she could live
her life
out of a backpack there would probably
be something else there that she would
have to address
yeah i would imagine i mean you could
probably speak to this that she might
not
feel like she's making that choice like
it feels like something that she has to
do
yeah um so it's not like she's like oh i
really this is an ideal that she
chooses to have but it's more like she
started on this thing and now she just
has
she feels like she has to keep going i
think i think that's true with most of
us though like
probably all of us like especially when
we're
caught up in the status quo if you're
working a nine-to-five
cubicle job this is what i have to do
right now it's great if
that is bringing you satisfaction and
joy and fulfillment wonderful
uh if you feel like you have to do
anything though i would probably start
questioning that well i was just
speaking to like the kind of the ocd
i know i know but so especially with the
ocd whenever i feel like i have to do
something
have you ever seen the movie matchstick
men no oh yeah yeah so it's uh
the main character has ocd and there's a
point where i've watched it with my wife
before and like
he's at home like cleaning the bottom of
the chairs with a with a toothbrush
and like everyone looks at that like
it's crazy i look at that like oh maybe
i should do that
i didn't think how do you work with it
when you have like this kind of
you start to tighten onto an idea of
something you think you have to do
anytime i feel like i must do something
i question the must
right and and because uh you realize and
i learned
this from you early on as you're
complete in an empty room right
and so like any activity that i need to
do anything that i need to acquire
better amplify and or enhance my
experience of life
and what i'm learning from you right now
is
this gear that you're getting for any of
these these activities that you're
interested in currently what i know
about you
in your life is if you're like you know
what i hate trail running
you're not going to hold on to the gear
you're going to let go of or if you're
like hey you know what that served me
really well but i think i'm done with
this now
you're not going to continue to cling to
the thing that's no longer serving a
purpose in your life
that's right now with her there is a
a clinical term it's a type of ocd
called spartanism
are you familiar with this no so it's uh
you're familiar with what hoarders are
sure um that's one side of the ocd
continuum the other side of the ocd
continuum is spartanism
so hoarding means i can't let go of
anything
right spartanism means i can't hold on
to anything
now it usually starts with the stuff but
the same way that hoarding ruins other
aspects of our life spartanism
people they i know a person who suffers
from spartanism
and he sabotaged every relationship that
he had
he he could i mean eventually he ended
up homeless because he couldn't he
couldn't even deal with
having a place to live he forsook his
family
because he he had to let go of
everything he felt like he
holding on to anything was was not
sustainable for him
and so yeah i mean if you if you're
feeling like that i would encourage you
to get
professional help from someone yeah it
doesn't seem to me like you've you've
gone that far
and it's just stuff right now and if
you're living to minimize
then then what we need to replace the
minimizing with because ryan said it's
not a destination
it's a it is the the path so to speak
right
toward something more meaningful you
need to figure out what is meaningful to
you krista
yeah one thing i want to throw out there
too for krista uh it does sound like
she's seeking professional help and i
have
had to get professional help many times
in my life and the easy part is showing
up
and talking to that person but the
hardest part is doing the work that
they're asking you to do
so krista if you're doing the work that
this professional is asking you to do
you are you are so much more likely to
change your perspective and to change
your habits doesn't mean that the
feeling won't be there but you'll
certainly be able to deal with it better
so i'm just encouraging her to like
do the work well anna can i ask uh add
one last thing
for sure um is one practice that's
really helped
me is compassion for myself
and so like a lot of times when i'm
struggling with one of these things
we've mentioned like overwhelm or like
you know
frustration with family members and for
her it sounds like she's struggling with
like i just really need to like
there's like a tightness here of needing
to get rid of her stuff
to the point where it's not really
helping her right um
just giving herself compassion and this
is a like a heart practice that you can
do
if you look up if you haven't done this
before look at meta
meditation m-e-t-t-a it's a
loving-kindness meditation and you can
do it for others
like i wish you you know the best and
the end of your suffering and
love and happiness but you can do it for
yourself too and just really seeing
where you're suffering
and this is really hard for you and just
giving yourself compassion
and i think that once you start to do
that maybe the practice
to take on besides that is like
a loosening practice that she really has
a
tightening kind of tendency and for some
people it's like oh i'm just
gonna have all this stuff and they need
to like get a little tighter
and more like rigorous and for her rigor
is already the thing and she needs like
love
and like a little bit of loosening so
it's like we
we could go to one side or the other and
we have to kind of like make these
course adjustments and come towards the
middle
between that like loosen loose like love
space which some people are
always in and like too much rigor and
then it's like
how do you find the the middle ground
there yeah it's a fixed state
and that's what we need to realize in
fact we even use that term
i need to fix my life right
no life is not fixed it is constantly
expanding
growing contracting you know there are
different chapters throughout your life
and right now you're at a place where
you're like okay i've minimized i've
made
room for a more meaningful life what do
i fill it with now
so chris so let me send you a copy of
our book uh it's our first book we ever
wrote
back in 2011 although this is a new
edition it's just a few years old it's
called minimalism live
a meaningful life and ryan and i we
figured out for us there were five sort
of core values we needed to fill our
life with
once we were there actually foundational
values once we
got rid of the excess stuff in our life
it's like okay now this is feeling empty
what do i
fill it with now for me the longest time
was i'll just fill it with more stuff
new stuff better stuff bigger stuff more
expensive stuff
but we already knew that didn't work for
us right and so
i didn't want to make the same mistake
and so we identified these five
foundational values of your health
relationships
growth contribution creativity passion
and and really figuring out what was
important to us you know you could say
prioritizing
our lives in a different way and so if
you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of minimalism live a
meaningful life or if you want the book
book or the ebook version i'm happy to
send those to you
as well krista ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
your text messages you can text your
questions and comments 2 to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts go
to both of our phones and we reply to as
many people as we can and
even respond to some on the podcast now
leo during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i and our guest
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response
no pressure we actually just we ramble
on a little bit and then
we podcast sean finds something pithy
that he can tweeze out put in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media we have a
question
from cheyenne can you discuss how we
should approach the leap
between decluttering and simplifying to
live
a meaningful life or a life with purpose
yeah so so leo let's talk about this uh
the leap between decluttering and
simplifying so we'll just call it
decluttering
uh to living a life with purpose so we
kind of touched on that a moment ago
because
i think here's here's something that's
confusing for folks
they think well minimalism i'm just
going to get rid of my stuff
and then all of a sudden it's perpetual
bliss
that i'm going to live a manic life of
of
always 10 out of 10 happiness
contentment joy pleasure
and uh that's not my experience at least
yeah you already have over 140
characters by the way
now sean's a good editor we're good okay
i have something pithy for you but i
just want to get
your thoughts first yeah um for me
what happened was i used simplifying and
decluttering to
clear some space to really start to
explore
what my purpose was so i didn't i didn't
have that at first i wasn't clear
but i i had the breathing room now and i
can now start to get closer to myself
and what what matters to me
let's talk about what it kind of looked
like when you started letting go
of some stuff there's obviously that
freeing feeling you feel lighter
um but what what else did you notice as
you st
if you if you tap back to 2005 2006 2007
you're letting go of stuff
what what did you feel in your life was
there an uncertainty there
before i started or when i was starting
as you were as you were letting go yeah
yeah
um the part that that led me into it or
the
or the like what the process felt like
as you were letting go of of
excess stuff and you started questioning
things in your life what kind of
feelings did you have and did that
include any uncertainty
i i actually felt incredible liberation
like it was like so freeing i'm sure you
guys can relate to for sure
that at some points but uh yeah i i
loved it and i was like oh
what else can i get rid of so it's just
like this adventure of like oh
this and this and like let's clear out
the whole you know
family room now and uh and then i
the other experience the uncertainty
that actually came up for me was around
my family and they're like whoa whoa
let's put the brakes on a little bit
right um don't get rid of my stuff
and i'm like okay um so let me slow down
now and like
uh play with that so it was it was uh
the uncertainty
um i really enjoyed the uncertainty of
like what would life be like
so it was a question what would life be
like without all this
excess stuff and i i could like even
feel as i was doing it there's more
breathing room for me
but the uncertainty really was when i
started meet up against my family
yeah um which was actually the like i
said the most rich
area it's easy when you're like a
bachelor as you guys
know like yeah right well i i get to
decide right
yeah um but when you're not and you're
in a relationship like that's
that's for me where the real uncertainty
came up for sure yeah
i'm going to put the answer for you
right and let's see what this uh
if this comports with yours uh conforms
with yours
decluttering won't give you a purpose
but it just might uncover a more
meaningful life
and so that's my my tweet worthy version
of what we're talking about here ryan
what do you got for us
that's good um you know uh before i read
this pet the answer i do want to say
like when i
first decluttered so i sold my condo i
got rid of my car payment i moved into a
smaller place
um got my bills you know from like 5 000
a month to like a thousand
i mean it was just like really really
simplifying
and it felt good to be there but man
when i was alone
and when i had all that breathing room
it was uncomfortable
like i wish i could just be like yeah i
simplified my life and now i'm happy
but it was this process of really
understanding what it meant
to me to live a purpose-filled life to
to live a meaningful life and
uh what it really turns out to be is you
know changing the relationships that i
had in my life like that's
really where i kind of started getting
ideas on what i wanted to do
so my pithy answer is this to live a
purposeful life
surround yourself with purpose-filled
people
and i'll tell you when i started to hang
around people who were living
a meaningful life who who were
simplifying it was just a great
um batch of recipes to kind of choose
ingredients from and it helped me to
help me to like really choose how to
move forward yeah i think there were a
lot of
you know toxic relationships in both of
our lives oh yeah or early on i don't
know if you experienced any of that
leo but with us and even the ones that
weren't toxic they may have been toxic
for
us you know how some people can have the
uh
are allergic to certain foods right like
ryan can eat a a gluten sandwich or a
fine
bucket of nails yeah and he'll be fine
for me if i you know if i eat certain
things it really messes me up and
and i think the same is true with our
relationship sometimes it's not that the
other person's toxic it's that the
relationship can be
toxic it's just not not working out for
whatever reason and many of our
relationships i felt
early on especially back in the
corporate world they were birthed out of
proximity or convenience right it's like
oh we happen to
work in the same on the same floor in
our offices
next to each other but we didn't share
similar values we didn't share similar
interests we just had
a career that coincided for that period
of time but
i was spending 90 of my time with people
like that and forsaking the people
closest to me as a result i do want to
talk more about
uncertainty in this this idea of
uncertainty training i think we'll get
to that on the maximal episode
we have some listener tips and comments
coming up here we also have an added
value segment
which is very leo focused today or i
think it's leo adjacent
at least and we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week leo like
what steps do you take to block out the
noise to stay focused how do i
identify and address unconscious
thoughts and fears that stop me from
decluttering
how do i minimize over consumption of
information
and misinformation we're also going to
discuss essentialism
environmentalism veganism buddhism
why you should stop trying to be
productive why you should get rid of
your goals
being a minimalist with six kids in a
big city
plus a million more questions for leo
babada and if you want to hear all that
subscribe to our maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast
it's a completely separate podcast and
is the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because we
don't believe in ads by the way if
you're not a private podcast subscriber
you're literally missing two-thirds of
our show plus hundreds of hours of
past private episodes so try it out for
a week or a month you can listen to the
back catalog
see if it's for you and also listen to
our episode with leo this week it's
cheaper than a cup of coffee or a cup of
tea yes yes indeed
head on over to the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
leo the the maximum episode is really
where we we let our hair down so we
brought a wig in
for you right what else you got for us
this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
hi it's chris from barry ontario canada
if you guys are looking for a good news
source that's
unbiased um that isn't very full of
clutter and garbage and junk
i would recommend a podcast called the
world next week by the corn
council on foreign relations
and uh it's a very non-biased great
source of just
um information on what's going on in the
world
and i just think it's a great resource
and it's very unbiased
and anyways i just wanted to leave that
little tidbit behind
hi my name is helen i'm from vista
california
and i wanted to respond to something i
heard today about
medals and trophies i'm a runner and i
had collected
30 years of all kinds of metals and
recently just got rid of
all of them i did donate to metal to
metal that was one of the resources that
was given today
but i also found that teachers were very
interested in them
trophies as well because they like to
give them out to kids
not necessarily for them to take home
just as a like
great job staying on task keep this on
your desk for a while kind of rotating
through the classroom so
my teachers that i knew took a ton of
them
and i made several more into christmas
tree ornaments because i do still have
some of those and then a tip that i
heard from somebody else for future is
when i get a medal at another race i'm
going to take a picture of it
and take a picture of myself with the
medal and i'm going to
give it away to somebody else there's
always families there cheering on moms
or dads so maybe a kid
who would enjoy it um so they don't
accumulate
anymore for me all right y'all thanks
again to leo babala for joining us today
you're awesome
thank you brother thanks for having me
this is fun uh zenhabits.net is the
place to be
uh you are on twitter at zen i think
it's still underscore habits isn't it
yeah that's right
okay the one without it oh okay
uh you can follow leo there um and also
he has a bunch of courses um we're gonna
talk more on the maximum episode about
uncertainty training but if
uh they want to check out your courses
it's all over at zenhabits.net as well
yeah look at the bottom and the the one
that i'm really
um diving into lately is fearless
training um
okay well i i what i love about zen
habits uh in particular
zinhabits.net you also own the dot com
but like dot net so
vintage retro retro that's the cooler
it's the cooler url now it's like you
got it at some uh really cool store
and like atwater village or
los feliz yeah so um but what i really
like is i feel like
zen habits is like i mean it's one of
the most popular minimalist blogs in the
world or simple living blogs whatever
you want to call it
but it's also the simplest
is perfectly memetic of what you're
trying to communicate
and it's it's beautifully simple it's
it's not
simplistic it's not but it it
brushes the line with being as simple as
it possibly can
but still being effective i've seen some
websites that are
too simple where you're like is this
even a website like why am i even here
yours is incredibly helpful and
incredibly simple obviously no ads
anything like that but
um bravo for doing this for so long man
yeah thank you
um it's it's so rewarding as you guys
know so i
i don't think i'll ever quit yes indeed
man well we've got an added value
segment this week that's where we talk
about something that's been adding value
to our lives recently
and since leo is here every morning i
turn on
music uh when well once the whole
family's awake
and and so me and ella and bex we uh
i'll just turn on some music and it's
usually pandora for whatever reason
pandora is still
talk about cool i know we're talking
about
that but
um something about their stations they
still have
they create the best they have the best
algorithm anyway there's a
a zen garden uh radio a playlist that i
listen to
every morning and it's so calming it's
perfect way to start our days i used to
to start the days with a different
playlist but this one it's
oceanic sometimes it's it it feels like
i'm in a spa
in the mornings and and my daughter
loves she'll get up
on the couch she'll she'll like perch up
on the top of the couch like a cat
and look out the window for like half an
hour just listening to the ocean waves
or
the flutes playing it it's amazing so
sean if you could please
put a link to the pandora station uh zen
garden radio
is what it's called and i i spend the
4.99 a month on pandora this is not an
ad for them
um i but i spend the 4.99 a month to
avoid the advertisements because
imagine how terrible this is how
intrusive ads are right imagine you're
like
listen to the ocean all of a sudden it's
like hey have you tried
wendy's new quarter pounder recently are
you getting good sleep
[Laughter]
yeah so uh yeah check it out it's the
zen garden radio station on pandora real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists
we have a minimalist rule book we don't
actually believe there's an actual
minimalist rule book
leo but uh ryan and i over the last
decade or so
we've accumulated 16 rules for living
with less 16 rules that have helped us
what we've done with this it's a free uh
ebook by the way you can get it on our
website the minimalists.com
rulebook if you want to check it out and
some of these rules work really well for
us
but they're adjustable and i think i
learned this from you early on like
even the things that work for you aren't
going to work for your kids or your wife
and so
the important thing about rules is
having them but not having them be too
rigid
right and and so uh the minimalist rule
book 16 rules for living with less
ryan and i have things like the we call
it the 90 90 rule if you look at an item
and you're like
all right have i used this in the last
90 days if so great
i'm probably still getting value from it
if not will i use it in the next 90 days
be honest with yourself and then if not
i give myself permission to let it go
the 90 90 rule if that's too
extreme we'll make it the one year one
year rule like
and i think that's the nice thing about
it ryan i also did it's probably my
favorite thing that we've done in a very
long time
we did an audiobook version of that yeah
and we did like a little mini podcast
for each of the 16 rules
so you can check that out the
minimalists.com rulebook
and find some rules that you can apply
to your own life you can follow the
minimalist on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit the
minimalists.com tour to find a city near
you if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcasts at theminimalists.com you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails whenever we send
those
if you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it